what's up jeremy shap how are you sir
what's going on richard
good to hear your voice it's very good
to hear your voice and you know
i savor any opportunity
and they they don't come along very
often yes to talk about modern
pentathlon
which is my favorite sport
and and it it makes me
kind of unique in in american media
anyway it might be a little different in
hungarian media
serbian media but modern pentathlon is
my favorite sport
in borisone 1976 in montreal
he disgraced um
not only himself but really the entire
sport modern fantastic
and if your listeners are unfamiliar
with modern pentathlon
it is the um it is the olympic event
although of course it's not only
uh contested at the olympics which tries
as best as possible to approximate the
skills required of the napoleonic
courier
so it's fencing shooting running
swimming and riding perhaps the most
famous
olympic modern athlete was
george patton um general george patton
he was not yet a general
uh who i believe finished
he finished out of the medals but i
think in the top 10 in 1912 in stockholm
is that because he slapped the
competition speaking of uh nancy perry
no actually it's ironic um because
uh patton was actually undone
uh by his performance in the shooting
competition
that's true but anyway was a modern
fantastic competing for the soviet union
yes
i believe he is uh uh ukrainian
i i think he might still be alive
actually
he wouldn't be that old and he'd won a
medal in 72 in munich i think he was the
silver medalist in 72 in munich
but in 76 in montreal he rigged
his epay to register false
touches
how do you do that it's a good question
i i don't know the answer
he was caught he was caught and he was
disgraced
and he was shipped back home
unceremoniously yes
and um after that uh really
lived uh uh lived in ignominy
um in the in the final stages of the uh
soviet union
so jeremy um a couple things from this
number one
um you know uh i'm a big
modern pentathlon fantasy player so i
know all about this
um uh i i
i grabbed boris in my snake draft uh
earlier this year um not knowing
unfortunately the
uh the lush history of his uh ignominy
to use your big word that you just
dropped in there thank you
uh and then secondly i i don't even know
what else to say other than the fact
that chris brockman has
has fact checked you in real time and
then and this is
all spot on correct yeah so uh so george
patton
uh finished fifth in 1912. uh
i thought it was eighth and yeah i just
said out of the medal so i wasn't
expecting
you you said that you were technically
right and fun and boris onoshenko
is still with us 83 years young wow
i'd love to do a story about him i go to
i think he's in kiev isn't he
correct
jeremy jeremy tell me how that pitch
meeting goes for outside the lines how
does that pick me
how does it pitch me to for e60 which
how does it go
how does it go like that that would be
you know
more mainstream than most of those ideas
i try to get greenlit
that has that's a little sexy that one
you could put that on
you could put that on espn minus
actually i don't know how much time we
have i know you've gone no no no no
this is delightful i actually want to
retract
as much as i am of the story there's
something much more bizarre
easily the most bizarre story i ever
covered and and i covered
to some extent the kerrigan harding
thing because i was working for cbs
those olympics in low hammer which was
insane
yes um but i don't know if you remember
this
this really is number one okay and i
can't do it justice here
uh but many of your listeners will
remember this
uh there was an nhl forward mike danton
uh he was playing for the saint louis
blues at the time he previously played
the new jersey devils
and he went to prison after pleading
guilty
to murder conspiracy charges
and in in layman's terms he tried to
hire a hitman to kill his agent
david frost who had also been his youth
hockey coach
now in canada this was this i mean it
wasn't quite
the o.j simpson story but it was a much
bigger deal than it was here
sure uh but but this was a story that uh
i covered at the time it happened like
the week it occurred and then for years
i wanted to do a bigger story about it
and eventually mike
uh who at that time was freed from
prison
we'd pursued him in prison but after he
was uh
freed i went up to see him in nova
scotia where he was going to college
and he agreed to do an interview and
david frost who had been the target was
living in southern california
and he agreed to do an interview and it
led to probably the strangest story i've
ever
i've ever worked on um there's so many
layers i can't do it justice here
but that's the one uh that should be a
movie so uh
right oh sure i do remember that
okashenko retraction was a great
uh what was that a great uh allen pakula
movie of the 1970s that was real i think
it starred
right after like yeah or something like
that
so uh before i let you go jeremy um i
was going to ask you to recite the
royals in succession
uh but i don't want to do that to you uh
even though i'm more than happy to have
you do it
but uh i was thinking of actually
calling you to do it
i was thinking of actually calling you a
couple weeks ago
and i'll have you right now uh the
passing of
uh george thomas seaver sir uh what a
beautiful photograph you put of your dad
interviewing what him and and muhammad
ali or him and namath together or
something like that
yeah it's right name it's on i think the
first edition of the joke name is
showing
in 69. so go go for it on the on the on
the siever front your memory of him the
first time you met him or your dad's
relationship with him
yeah please well so i was born august
23rd 1969
obviously that won the world series
about seven weeks later
and fever was the biggest sports star
maybe in the country at that time after
the incredible season that he'd had and
then
that offseason he my father wrote a book
together
and they'd already known each other you
know i think for a couple of years you
know he was a rookie in 67
and they wrote a book together which was
you know
which was siever's memoir at the age of
25
of the perfect game uh and it's centered
around game four only series but i grew
up
you know my dad was very close uh to
siever
we lived in the same community in
connecticut for a few years
i mean some of those memories like could
you really have a memory because you're
so young but you told it so often that
it feels real but yeah when i was like
two or three
my dad came home uh with a couple of
cats from a litter himalayan cats
and and we kept one uh and
my father named named ours um
gandhi after gandhi yes himalayan
vaguely indian
of course uh yeah well not vaguely but
you know um
and and tom uh took the other cat the
sievers took the other cat
and they named thayers ferguson because
he had just lost the cy young award in
1972
to ferguson jenkins and so
you know i didn't see much of time after
that growing up sir you know i
once in a while but you know i always
felt this connection because our cats
were brothers
and i think it's one of those i kind of
have some memory of hit
him missing a spring training start
because the cat got loose
in florida and he spent days looking for
it
but um you know when my dad
died 20 years ago you know these are the
things that stick with red years
you've experienced this recently you
know the things people tell you when
your dad dies and
um you know tom wrote me this beautiful
letter
and it just meant so much to me a
handwritten note
and you know he's you know me and you
were born the same time in new york in
that era you know you couldn't be a
bigger star than tom seaver
and uh so many my childhood memories in
my sports fandom is just wrapped up
in who he was and what he represented
the greatness and the professionalism
um and i remember when i heard the news
a few like five years ago that he was
seriously sick
right you know it was just crushing
jeremy
love you man how's life everything good
everybody jocelyn good kid's good
everybody good yes
okay thank you yeah you know it's it's
it's interesting
you know so um but we can all say that
now i know that
well look it's always interesting when
you chime in on our poll question about
boris ogacenko or whatever oh my bad i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i'm i'm sorry and i had it again he was
telling you another modern pentathlon
story you know my father's getting into
trouble with usoc
uh this is true this is in the early 90s
he was friendly with the best
uh u.s modern pentathlete rob stahl i
don't know where rob is now okay
um but my they had no money the usoc
back then and it's federation some of
them were so poorly funded they couldn't
send our team to the world championships
which i believe were taking place
in budapest in hungary but maybe it was
novi sad
yugoslavia anyway so um through some of
my father's connections
uh they ended up getting sponsored by a
topless bar in lawrence kansas
um this is a true story the us modern
pentathlon team
and um usoc was not amused that's pretty
much the whole story ladies and
gentlemen
everybody you're the best jeremy you
take care of yourself buddy
thank you richard much love that's it
that's jeremy shot hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here